we have will and mark you're both well
big I think high points in both of your
careers where your willingness to appear
in underwear and oh they were great and
I was looking at them side by side today
and it's pretty stunning you learned at
the both of you yeah let's take a look
at that it's really stunning
twelve years old
it's almost like Vince is looking at me
going why can't you look more like
Marvel did you just get stabbed and cut
you that's unfortunately my natural
physique yeah
and of course Mel and John we didn't
want to leave you guys out so we have a
picture here side-by-side as well these
are again great moment
[Applause]
Wow number 10 chicken up down there I
don't remember that episode after well
around the nice thing is that way at
that very moment on my line was have you
no shame
look at me now very nice very nice I
just want to get those out there those
posters are available in the lobby on
the way oh you get the money yeah I
guess
[Applause]
you